peut voir déjà les bosses on peut voir
les les hématomes elle avait aussi une
plaie énorme comme ça sur le corps que
j'ai essayé de les nourrir devant eux
parce que j'avais acheté à manger on
m'interdissait et le chat il est
maltraités personne me personne ne veut
pas tout le monde s'en foutait en fait
donc détacher oui non je n'ai pas le
droit le chien soit disant bouge partout
il fait chier je suis parti j'ai regardé
le chien une dernière fois je dis
t'inquiète pas dans ma tête c'était
t'inquiète pas je vais pas te laisser là
je vais te sauver en gros un chiot comme
ça en une soirée on ne peut pas lui
faire ça on voit déjà que les boss ça
fait quand même un peu longtemps
il vous accuse vous en fait non oui oui
m'accuse clairement moi mais là il faut
savoir qu'ils sont placés en garde à vue
déjà pourquoi il vous accuse le buzz
c'est des gens qui n'ont aucune valeur
qui n'ont évidemment pas la valeur du
travail on a vu ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont pas la valeur du respect on découvre
ce soir qui n'ont aucune humanité moi
ces images je peux même pas les voir
elle me brise le cœur et pardon mais il
faut être quel genre de merde pour
tabasser un chiot qui peut pas se
défendre